hey there guys if you're getting this
message then I am dead sorry no not dead
I've had a baby and that means that I'm
incredibly excited and happy but I'm not
gonna be uploading videos to this
channel for a little while
for obvious reasons or rather I'm not
gonna be uploading new videos I've
created quite a few which I'm hoping to
upload slowly in the kind of pipeline
but some of them might need tweaking I
like just can't tell you for sure right
now how my video uploading schedules
gonna be I'm on a 2.5 week paternity
leave so so Phidias slow down then
please bear with me I will be back soon
in the meantime you can also check out
the blog where I'll be uploading lots of
posts as per usual also you can now buy
bio near t-shirts I'll be leaving the
link in the description down below you
can also get tank tops I'll be adding
hoodies and other merchandise there soon
a lot you guys asks we could get by a
near merchandise so if you want to
support the channel and if you want to
be a pioneer then check that out I'll
also be putting the links on the website
over at the bio near comm also is always
exclusive content over at patreon calm
thank you so much to all of you who are
already supporting me over there and
I'll be doing some shout outs in future
videos as well as maybe some giveaways
and some free content so check it out
again if you'd like to support the
channel that way also as some of you
know I've been working on a book called
thriving in the gig economy where I talk
about how to work online how to learn
online become a digital polymath how to
build a business and travel and
lifestyle design and if that's something
you're interested in if you've liked any
of my videos previously on that kind of
stuff then again I'll leave the link in
the description down below the digital
versions are already available to buy
and if you want the print version that
will be available in the next few months
but you can pre-order it right now so
you'll have it just after Christmas also
something that's very cool it has a
foreword by cold fusion to go-go I'll
trade who I've worked with in the past
thanks a ton for your support guys and I
hope that I can upload enough content
for you sorry if I'm a bit quiet but I
just also wanted to say thank you so
much for all your congratulations and
well wishes at this time I really
appreciate it you guys are all super
supportive and as always you've helped
to grow this channel to be an awesome
success we're now over sixty thousand
subscribers and I'm aiming for a hundred
thousand
halfway into next year let's see if we
can make that happen so thanks a ton for
watching guys and stay tuned more is on
the way I might just be quiet for a
little while thanks time for watching
bye for now